taylor i wanted to bring this up to you
why i have you here
have you noticed i talked to kristin
your co-star from the twilight franchise
a while back and i was like there is
this mass resurgence of twilight and my
kids even getting into it on netflix
it's weird because it doesn't feel it
feels incredibly far away and also still
not that far away from me whatever
i'm just glad to get away from all those
reeking blood suckers
i'm sorry i know
they're the good guys
for a while there for the past few years
before that happened it kind of it was
just like the twine moms stopping me in
the street
because yeah it kind of just like
outgrew itself and it was in and i love
the twi moms it is wild is making a
comeback kristen was just said kind of
the same thing about it she was like oh
my god it's crazy to bring it back now
because now it feels old all of a sudden
right because it's coming back
yeah classic classic not old classic
classic
on one hand you're like oh i'm old my
god i feel like that was five minutes
ago
now it's like 10 year anniversary and i
was like wow i have to go to my high
school anniversary already only recently
has it like resurged and we have like
these like young teenagers you know
starting to to watch it and it is it's
crazy to see it come back around
connor jason you guys are gonna be our
tortilla chips that means dennis and
marcos you're our lime wedges you're
right here which makes our hot sauce
that's brian ryan's more of a napkin
and we're going green right formation
that's our initial formation ever you're
with me yeah yeah great you play coaches
in this thing there's a there's a
camaraderie there's an understanding and
what'd you guys do to get that dynamic
right between the two of you was there
bonding on and off screen how did what
was the hang time like with you two for
me i'm gonna speak first taylor i hope
you don't mind i'm just taking this one
because taylor makes everything i was
just talking about this you're fortunate
enough to work in this business you know
there's a lot of people you meet that
aren't as great as they should be and
then there's others like like literally
i put taylor up there with like jerry
stiller i got to work with jerry stiller
henry winkler like the nicest guys
in the business that you just go my
goodness and taylor taylor is one of
them my good he is it's
amazingly easy to work with a guy who
can roll with uh everything improv
talent funny
and in the middle of any conversation he
could just he could do a backflip to to
punctuate a sentence
you know if he needs to put an emphasis
yeah
it does help
and uh no he's just the greatest
honestly he's an amazing dude and you
know
thrilled to work with him on this one
wow i don't even know what to say to
that
you don't say anything man that's it
that's literally it
don't try to try to back it up don't try
to match it with how great i am i know
how great i am you don't need to do any
of that just stop just stop it because
all it's going to do
all it's going to do is just add to you
how great you are by trying to do it to
me so don't even do it you just walk
away from it yeah this is awkward
because i was thank you yeah okay i
won't say how difficult it was working
with kev
there you go
there you go
see that's me beating the punch i beat
to the punch if you do this then he goes
oh i can't see anything
not your first rodeo
taylor tell me about how much did you
know about this kind of uh this is based
you know somewhat on on truth right this
is the saints coach what'd you know
about the backstory here uh i knew a lot
um i knew a lot because uh
i actually i'm friends with sean um and
i met sean
while i was filming the last two
twilight movies in battle room and he
invited me to a home game
and gave me headphones i stood on the
sideline with all the players and the
team and watched the game from the
sidelines made friends with him and came
back for almost every home game um and
then it's kind of a crazy full circle
story uh sean and his daughter were
visiting me on the set of ridiculous six
and his daughter met christopher tytone
who is adam sandler's brother-in-law
they've been together ever since
and he chris ended up writing this movie
about megan's dad it's it's kind of wow
wow that's interesting like kevin what
was your what did you know about this
story getting into this thing how are
you connected to that whole that whole
field there i was only connected to it
as far as sandler called me and said
that uh chris wrote this great story
about uh this idea and he pitched the
idea to me and he goes i don't want to
you know if you if you'd be into it or
not whatever take a look at it
and as soon as i heard the story i was a
hundred percent sold so i was like i'm
totally in it's an it's an amazing story
congratulations by the way we at et
always uh want to send congratulations
we know you just got engaged uh anything
you could tell us about wedding planning
we love these feel-good moments so much
how's it going for you oh man thank you
so much you guys have you were super
supportive of the engagement so thank
you
to be honest we're kind of just enjoying
this period because we're super excited
so we haven't started any sort of
planning um
we're kind of really just soaking this
all in um so we're gonna take it one day
at a time but i could not be happier i
feel so blessed now that you got taylor
in the in the kind of the kevin and the
adam sandler and this whole family are
you guys planning bachelor party you got
bachelor party ideas for for the young
buck here yes we've already we were way
ahead of you
there's a whole situation going on and
the fact that you just brought it up
right now ruins it a little bit because
taylor's
he didn't know about it and it was going
to be
a big surprise but i might as well tell
you well no i'm not going to tell you
we're going to have to hold off and see
but yes we've we've got a bunch of bunch
of surprises lined up and uh believe me
we will not disappoint wow i can't wait
to hear this yeah yeah that's right
that's right